hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the start of the US
Chess Championship 2022 it's a game from
round one uh with the white pieces
Christopher would you knew and with the
black pieces Han smoking Neiman yeah
it's a it's a great game you guys will
will love it and uh well let's dive
straight into it and the things are very
very serious over there Arbiters are
taking their uh job uh incredibly
seriously here you can see they are even
even scanning hans's banana uh for for
any uh sort of a transmitting device or
or whatnot so they are very very
thorough uh so that being said let's
check out the game so Christopher has
the white pieces and he opens with D4 we
have Knight to F6 by Hans Knight the C3
D5 and now Bishop to F4 going for the
jobava London system which is very
interesting as Hans made adjustable
course on that exact opening so let's
see what happens Ponto E6 we have Knight
to B5 now putting pressure on the
C7 pawn and now Knight to A6 of course
you have to defend the pawn E3 and now
Bishop to E7 so all been played before
nothing new here Knight to F3 we have
castles and Bishop to E2 Knight the H5
now going after the bishop s the bishop
is behind the pawns the pawns are nicely
placed on dark squares so you want to
capture it in some point but the light
Square Bishop will be the strong Bishop
for white as this bishop can always be
captured so here Bishop to E5 and now
there is a game where C6 was played uh
but uh or rather a bit more of games
where a C6 was played but there are far
uh less uh where F6 was played so here
Bishop to G3 Pawn to C6 now Knight back
to C3 and pawn to C5 by Hans
uh we have castles and now only now
Knight captures and G3 H captors and G3
and there are some games that read this
position for example Bishop D7 is a
known but here we have C4 by Hans and it
is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how the
game continues as Hans uh sort of
abandoned this the fight for the center
by pushing C4 uh Christopher now
advances e for and he strikes in the
center Bishop to B4 uh attacking the
Knight and now e captures on D5 e
captures and now Knight to B1 repairing
C3 uh to push away the bishop Knight the
C7 we have C3 and Bishop to D6 and now
Knight B to D2
uh here we have uh point the B5 hunts of
course at some point wants to play A5 B4
and so on and here Knight to E1 uh the
Knight is not coming the C2 then maybe
the E3 but also will have additional
control over the B4 Square so many uh
useful things for this Knight with
Bishop to E6 and now Knight the C2 we
have Queen to D7 and now Rook the E1 uh
putting the Rook on the open E file and
now Pawn to A5 further expanding on the
queen side A3 stopping any B4 ideas and
now Pawn to G6 by hands now uh saying
that he's preparing H5 and H4 uh we have
Knight to F1 again re-maneuvering the
Knight Ponte H5 and now Queen to D2
hoping to infiltrate with Queen to H6 so
Hans plays King to G7 and now we have
Ponte F4 grabbing full control over the
E5 Square Rook the h8 announcing the
advancement of the Ponte H4 and now
Bishop to F3
and this is the position a lot of people
were discussing online because it's it's
a wonderful position for black there are
many possibilities you can try many
different ideas uh but what's
interesting is that uh Hans plays a move
that is not recommended by any engine or
any a line by by stockfish that's why
it's um yeah it's such a fun move
because here if you let the engine
crunch the numbers to let's say depth 40
you will get moves like let's say Rook 8
f a uh rookie to fade you will get moves
like Bishop to F7 getting the bishop off
of this e file you will get moves like
the instant H4 which was kind of the
idea behind putting the Rook on h8 but
Hans plays Ponte F5 and this is just a
very very positional a nice positional
idea uh Anish gear even posted on
Twitter
uh saying that Hans played F5 to make
the pony on C7 smile uh the idea being
that now the F6 square has been vacated
for the Knight and you can play Knight
A8 to F6 and then land the Knight on e4
or even G4 depending on what white plays
so okay uh here we have Rook to E2 you
could also play Rook to E5 because now
the light Square Bishop is basically a
pawn so if you trade this Rook for for a
bishop for a dark score Bishop your your
position should be okay that's something
similar happened in the game so first
rookie two uh we have Knight the E8 now
beginning the journey Rook 8 to E1 and
now Bishop to F7 getting the bishop out
of Harm's Way Rook to E5 hoping to give
up The Rook for the dark Square Bishop
but of course Hans is not interested in
that Knight to F6 Knight F to E3 and now
only Now Pawn to H4
attacking the G3 Pawn we have Queen to
F2 and now Pawn to H3 now attacking the
G2 pawn and here we have Rook the E2
yeah and this is a very very uh
interesting uh position because you
could play Knight captures on D5 but
it's very very hard to calculate this
because the pawn is hanging for example
Knight captures on D5 it seems that uh
you should not be able to do this
because there's Bishop captures on E5
and now your knight is just hanging the
problem is there's Knight the B6
attacking the queen and the rook and
once the queen moves now you play F
characters on E5 and you attack the
Knight with the Rook still hanging and
if Queen character seriously captures an
F6 with check Queen captures and now you
trade everything the shop captures Rook
captures and now let's say G captures
and H3 and white is very happy with this
position uh it's it's a better position
he's up a pawn so perfectly fine uh the
problem is white of course black is not
forced to do this after this Knight
captures on D5 you can simply Play
Bishop after sun D5 not go for this
silly Discovery and now just Bishop
captures on D5 and The Rook 8 fate and
it's a very very very tricky position
where white would have to really find
some nice moves like Bishop to E6 that
challenge the queen and if Queen to B7
are just to Rook 5 back to E2 and it's
uh I mean it's crazy position the the
pawn can capture Queen also attacks G2
the H file will be open for The Rook uh
so the engine gives it as as completely
equal but it's a very very hard position
to even imagine so here Rook the E2 by
Christopher we have Rook 8 to d8 now and
queen to E1 tripling up on the E file
Knight the E for now by Hans and now
Pawn to G4 uh just uh putting pressure
on that F5 Pawn we have Bishop captures
on E5 by Hans this is sort of a a forced
winning position for black but again
right it's a very cool line I will just
show it because I know you guys enjoyed
very much age captures and G2 so you
start with this and it's similar to what
actually happened in the game only
Christopher took a bit of a different
turn Rook captures on G2 now Rook H3 uh
attacking the bishop and now after
Bishop capture Cindy captures G captures
on F5 opening up the G file for the
white Rook but now Rook D to h8 and now
look at this Rook H1 followed by Rook
captures anyone how do you how do you
escape this if Queen E2 then you simply
Play Bishop captures on E5 now and after
F captures an E5 Rook H1 check King F2
and now Rook 8 the H4 going for Rook to
F4 so if white stops this then you play
Rook to H5 now putting more pressure on
this F5 pawn and if F6 check you just
play King f8 you don't care because it's
the white king that's gonna be attacked
and if D5 it seems like you're getting
destroyed here as black uh there's Rook
to HD check and now if Rook G2 that just
the very nice Queen H3 so there are many
lines here this is just the
nicer one that I decided to show putting
pressure on on the G2 pawn and it
doesn't really matter let's say queen G4
you can pick up the the rook and G2 now
if Knight captures then the queen hangs
because the Knight is defending the
queen and if Queen captures then just
Rook H2 you pick up the uh the queen and
that's it characters captures and now
after King T1 you can even pick up the
pawn so there's no counter play here so
basically after G4 Hans did not go for
the immediate capture he plays Bishop
captures on E5 first but we sort of get
into that line uh D captures an E5 H
capture Sun G2 Rook captures on G2 and
not Rook the H3 so very similar going
after the bishop but now uh not Bishop
captures on e4 like we've shown uh
rather E6 is played it's a very cool
idea by Christopher he wants something
to be an E6 while when he captures this
so it comes with Tempo so here Bishop
captures on E6 was played the G captures
on F5 Bishop captures Knight captures
with check Queen captures and now unite
the D4 attacking the queen and now if
the black queen moves from the control
over the E6 where the Knight to D6 check
will pretty much seal the deal yeah but
of course hunt will defend the E6 Square
he plays Queen to F4 uh Bishop captures
on e4 and now not recapturing but here
Hans plays the wonderful Rook to E8 and
even though the G6 spawn is hanging uh
it doesn't matter Rook captures uh
anyone will come with checks so if you
play this Rook captures Queen captures
Bishop captures this just comes with
check and now you have two Rooks against
the bishop in the Knight King G2 you're
just gonna play Rook e to H1 and there's
no escaping this even after Bishop F5
something like this you will even give a
check and pick up the the beat you Pawn
defend the B4 Pawn at the B5 Pawn so
there's no control play here so instead
after rookie 8 here we have Pawn to F5
blowing very aggressively
against the the G6 spawn and now just
Rook captures an E4 with check Queen to
F2 and now Rook eat the H for
threatening mate in one with Rook to H1
check and there's no way to play this
again it seems like you can win because
Rook captures and G6 will win the black
queen uh but it's only temporarily and
of course if you start running away
that's not gonna do anyone any good
Quirk King E2 Queen E5 check and that's
it King to D2 now you have control over
the H2 Square just to Rook for to H2 and
the white I really can't move here again
there are some threads you could like
play upon to F6 but black just doesn't
care black just plays King F7 and
there's nothing more to be done here if
Knight E6 check you just play King F6
and if Rook G6 and even King the E7
there's uh no no move you can make here
Queen is hanging so here what you could
do after this uh move you you can play
the instant root captures on G6 but just
King F7 and there's no continuation here
I mean there's uh there's nothing your
queen is just hanging so so here after
Rook eth4 Rook captures and G6 was
played right away Queen captures on G6
and giving up the queen for the moment F
characters and G6 and now just to Rook
the H1 with check King G2 and Rook 4 to
H2 with another check so now
uh Hans will win back the queen but more
importantly he will win the beat you
Pawn so King to G3 Rook captures on F2
King captors now Rook to H2 with check
and now the B2 Pawn Falls King E3 Rook
characters on B2 guarding the B5 pawn
and now the G6 Pawn will fall as well
and you're just up to much material King
F4 King characters on G6 King E5
Here pawn to B4 I'm just busting through
eight captures eight captures C capture
some B4 but now Pawn to C3 we have B5
here Rook captures on B5 Hans even gives
up The Rook for the uh for the uh well
end of the game Christopher cap respond
to C2 and he was in this position on
move 54. that Christopher wujinyu
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so very nicely done
of course any move you make next move
Hans just brings a queen into the game
this is Unstoppable so quite uh quite a
nice game by Hans with the the black
pieces in this very very
uh cool line uh against the jobava
London system and like I said uh Hans
made an adjustable course on this and
it's very interesting that um
Christopher prepared this exactly this
against Hans but obviously Hans knew
what he was um what he was doing while
recording that uh well uh video series
uh so yeah and also after the after the
game Hans gave a little message to
everyone he said that this game is uh a
message to everyone the entire thing
started with me saying chess speaks for
itself and I think this game spoke for
itself and showed that the chess player
that I am it also showed I'm not going
to back down and I'm going to play my
best chess regardless of the pressure so
there we have it that's hans's comment
on everything that's uh that's been
going on very nice game from round one
of the US Championship 2022 we'll see
what happens and uh well what what what
other interesting uh things will the
future unfold uh so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Alan Bradbury as the grand storm
70 on bandcamp Daniel M sometimes and
antevetma for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and uh checking up on the
European Club cup us championship and
whatever else happens thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day